So I'm talking today with Nina Paley,
who's a brilliant animator and she's
making a variety of short films,
which I guess are going to be joined
together into a longer film about that
feature,
old testament themes,
and she's the creator of the animated
musical features.
Sita sings the blues,
her adventures in our broken copyright
system,
let her to join question,
copyright.org as artists in residence in
2008 where she produced a series of
animated shorts about intellectual
freedom called minute means or recently
she made this land is mine,
which is absolutely brilliant,
shocking,
a devastating and also aesthetically
impressive film about Israel Palestine,
Canaan,
the Levant,
and that's intended for her new feature
film sadomasochism.
And you can find a lot of Nina's pieces
of pieces of that film online.
And I would highly recommend watching
the wheel,
a couple of them into this interview so
that you can see what she's up to.
So I guess there's two things that we
could really talk about.
I think that most important one
obviously is your work,
but I guess the second one is your
concern for intellectual freedom and
your feeling with regards to two
copyrights.
Copying is not stealing and less less
copying.
It makes one thing.
That's what toppings for copying is not
the
one for me and one for you.
That's what God is doing.
There's one for each of us.
That is what we call copy sharing ideas
with everyone.
That's why it caught me,
but let's,
let's start.
Let's start by talking about you first
tell,
tell my listeners and tell me who you
are and where you come from and what
you're about.
You want to know about my identity.
I guess that's,
that's.
Yeah,
trust me to identify myself.
I don't trust myself there.
Well that's okay.
You're the best source we have today.
Actually.
I'm not,
am not sure about that.
Um,
I mean,
I think most of us would agree that I'm
an artist and currently an animator.
I guess I've been doing animation since
1998.
Uh,
before that I was a newspaper cartoonist
is still do comics from time to time.
Not very often,
I mean,
I guess the thing is I've just been,
I just came back from a bike ride and
I've just been thinking about identity
like all the time and how incredibly
unreliable it is and how I don't respect
it,
including ways that I identify myself.
Well I guess that's part of being an
artist,
you know,
because people who are artistic or high
in trait openness and that gives them a
very fluid identity.
I mean it's an advantage because people
who are high in openness can think
loudly and they're always coming up with
creative ideas,
but it does tend to make their identity
rather pluralistic and sometimes
unstable.
And that could also be a problem.
Well,
I guess I guess it's not even that it's
fluid.
It's not like,
oh,
I identify this way one day and this way
another day.
It's just,
I don't really currently have much
respect for the idea of identity at all.
Uh,
and I could say all kinds of things
about myself,
but you know,
does that actually do me any good?
Well,
let me ask you a couple of basic
questions.
Where do you live?
I live in Urbana,
Illinois.
That's verifiable.
Alright,
and where were you born?
I was born in her band.
So you've been there your whole life
essentially?
No,
I left when I was 20.
I moved to Santa Cruz,
California and I wanted to be a hippie.
I failed a.
But then you know,
I was already out on my own.
So I briefly moved to Austin,
Texas.
That didn't work out.
I moved to San Francisco in 1991.
I lived there for 11 years.
In 2002 I had followed my then
boyfriend.
Actually we were legally married,
so my then husband to India,
uh,
which is the subject,
one of the subjects of Sita sings the
blues.
And then later in 2002 I moved to
Brooklyn,
New York and lived in various places in
New York for a total of about 10 years.
I moved back to her Urbana in 2012 right
after my father died.
And here I am.
And so why did you move back to her band
and after all that adventuring?
First I was done with New York.
Even though I really love New York,
especially know my first five years
there,
I was fantastic.
I kind of achieved more than I even
expected I would be able to and started
to just get the love affair with New
York kind of wore off and I wanted a
little more peace and quiet and I wanted
cooler summers and I didn't want to
smell garbage everywhere all the time.
Uh,
I had an opportunity to move back here
because my dad died.
My mom was threatening to sell the
house.
I joined the occupy movement,
occupy moms house,
trying to keep her from selling that
house.
You actually had a specific demand with
your occupied movement.
Failed.
She sold the house anyway,
but I think in our new house,
yeah,
I was,
I was dating somebody that lived here
and uh,
that has ended,
but I actually really like it.
It's much more relaxed and inexpensive.
I get lots of fresh air.
I take lots of bike rides and I don't
really care about,
uh,
the less stressed out
identity less.
Yes.
Well you have plenty of adventure,
so obviously.
So I guess it must take a fair bit of,
I would think time of quiet and,
and,
and some isolation in order to work on
your animation.
Yeah,
well I achieved that quite an isolation
in New York actually by just living in
New York in an apartment by myself.
I would rather live in New York than
visit New York because when you live
there you can actually control your
environment somewhat and you can shut
everything out.
Whereas when you're visiting usually
have to be out all the time being
overstimulated.
Rick.
Yes.
Well it's definitely an overstimulating
place.
So you.
When did you start doing your animation?
I started animating as an adult in 1998.
Before that I had done some animation
when I was 13 years old using a borrowed
super eight camera and I just completely
stopped because I was in central
Illinois and there was no support for
doing animation.
There was no way I could have advanced
beyond the neighbor super eight camera.
Uh,
but then in 1998 I was burning out of my
daily comic strip and wanted to do
something and borrowed somebody else's
super eight camera and in 1998 it was
easier to advance,
especially in San Francisco where a lot
of people were doing independent film
and yeah,
I just picked up where I left off.
I did plasticine clay stuff on super
eight and shared that film with a band
called Nick Phelps in the sprocket
ensemble that did live music to
animation and that was really fun.
I was being gratified by audience
feedback and so I made another film on
16 millimeter and then my next film was
drawing and scratching on 35 millimeter.
And then my next film after that was
drawing and scratching on Imax film,
which is 70 millimeter.
Really big frames.
And then I got into flash,
macromedia flash and I've been digital
ever since.
Are you using macromedia flash now?
What's your primary technology?
A lot of those clips for sadomasochism
more animated in macromedia flash,
adobe flash and crippled it and ruined
it in the opinion of many flash
animators.
So I'm still using macromedia flash from
1990 2007.
Is that when my copy of flashes from,
I don't know,
macromedia flash eight.
It only runs on older computers actually
I think it might be from 2006 or 2005.
So I have this old Mac here,
a running ios 10 point six because it
won't run on any more recent machines
and uh,
you know,
it's like impossible to integrate with a
modern video editing system.
So I have a new Mac as well.
And the newer parts though Sadomasochism
I'm using a program called Moho pro 12,
which is kept up and runs on modern
computers.
Yeah,
it's funny how sometimes software peaks
in terms of complexity and usability and
then it goes downhill,
you know,
I think we're seeing that not just with
software but with computers altogether,
like personal computers I think peaked
around 2007,
maybe 2010 and they've been getting
worse ever since.
Like any sort of upgrade to operating
systems just means more surveillance and
less user freedom at this point.
Yes.
As well as the steep learning curve.
What annoying.
If you happen to be an expert with the
previous system,
yeah.
Anyway,
I don't know if I don't know if I can
keep animating digitally,
uh,
because it,
you know,
like the software that I'm using now
motto,
I just found out that the person that
created it and was an integral part of
it's team this whole time just left the
company.
So,
uh,
you know,
we'll host faith is unclear and I'm
like,
if I have to learn a whole other piece
of software again,
I just don't know if I can take this
anymore.
I mean,
I'm so fluent with flash.
It took me years to become fluent at
all.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Well that's another thing is that it
takes a long time to become an expert
user of a complex software program and
then when it shifts the ground shifts
from underneath you,
it's rather disheartening because all of
that expertise is essentially
disappears.
And I guess it's part of what we're
experiencing as our technology advances
fast enough so that our lifespans are
too long really to keep up.
You know,
we get,
we get outdated and superannuated on
about a five year rotation and it does
get exhausting.
Yeah.
Well maybe I'll just die early.
Won't have to worry about that.
That'll solve the problem.
Then you won't feel finished your film.
And now it seems like a bad idea.
Well,
I'm going to finish this film.
I finally see the light at the end of
the tunnel for sadomasochism.
Good for you.
So,
so let,
let me ask you something about that.
So now you made this land is mine.
When was that?
That was in 2012 I think it was.
That's the first scene that I made.
God gave this
to me.
I
see.
So it's going to be the last scene in
the film,
but it's the first one that I made.
I see.
And what,
what possessed you to make that?
So I knew I wanted to make a movie about
Passover because I was ready to just
observing Passover,
although not much else.
And so I was doing research.
I'd never seen the movie exodus,
you know,
that movie.
I'd never seen it.
So I watched it as part of my research
and I learned that the theme music had
lyrics written to it by Pat Boone and
that it was a really popular song in the
sixties.
Tons of artists did it.
I'd never even heard it before.
So I heard it and I just thought it was
ridiculous.
Right?
This land is mine.
God gave this land to me.
I mean,
any.
Everyone would say that,
right?
Everybody,
every group feels that way about the
land that they're on,
every single one.
So the absurdity of it was just apparent
in the song and no,
there wasn't even really a process of
coming up with a concept for it.
It was just that was what the song
evoked for me.
It was just showing how every single
person,
or not every single person,
but every single tribe has that attitude
towards their land.
And so saying that this land is yours
and God gave this land to me,
gives you no authority at all because
every.
I mean that's just what it is to be a
tribe living on land.
So what's,
what sort of reaction did you garner
from this land is mine,
this land is mine is the most popular
thing I have ever made.
It's been viewed on various channels
more than 10 million times.
Uh,
and you know,
many people like it in terms of
criticism,
the criticism seems equally divided
between people that say that I'm a
Zionist and people that say I'm an anti
Zionist,
so it's either a really anti Zionist
film or it's a really Zionist film.
I see.
So you can just add that criticism
together in sum to zero and ignore it.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm really flattered by it,
right?
Because if people that passionately,
you know,
I'm on polar opposite sides are saying
that,
then I feel like I've really done
something.
Right.
Well,
you've definitely done something right.
I mean,
I think that was the first film of yours
that I saw and then I've watched many of
them.
I think everyone I could get my hands on
since then and instruct me in a variety
of ways.
I mean,
the first thing that's,
let's say strange about your animation
is that it's this.
If first of all,
you have great taste,
didn't use it,
I'll get the best.
And how do you get permission?
How do you be done to?
Good.
Oh,
you're doing.
I don't really,
really.
How's that working out for you?
Well,
okay.
In the case of this land is mine.
It's pretty clear cut,
fair use because the film is parody,
like I said it,
it's literally a parody of those lyrics
and you know,
that's fair use.
Uh,
I,
I actually think most of my uses are
fair use,
their transformative,
but a lot of uses are not as clear cut
as parody.
So that's actually a really interesting
issue with the film and how is this film
going to be released and how's it going
to be shown because there is no,
no way I am going to ask for permission
to use this music,
particularly music that entered my head
as a child,
uh,
which I did not consent to and I had no
control over it.
Of course nobody has any control over
what goes into your head,
right?
Like you'd go out in the world and music
is playing,
it goes into your head,
uh,
and yet once it's there,
that part of your head that it occupies
belongs to a corporation.
And I'm just done asking corporations
for permission to use what's in my head,
which they put there.
Okay.
So you basically solve the problem by
saying to hell with it,
I'm going to do this,
I'm going to do this no matter what.
And you're going to hire note whatever
difficulties there are with that as you
move along.
It's an illegal film.
I mean,
in the case of Sita sings the blues,
I Made Sita sings the blues when I was,
I was certainly questioning in
copyright,
but I didn't really see it as a
completely bankrupt institution.
So when that film was done,
I cleared all the rights,
which was an incredibly difficult
process and required hiring
intermediaries because the rights
holders don't talk to normal people.
So if you do make a film and you don't
have permission to use the music in it,
you can't simply ask for permission.
They won't talk to you.
So you have to pay lawyers.
And intermediaries,
just for them to even listen to you to
tell you how much money they're
demanding,
which is inevitably an absurd amount
that you can't afford.
But I ended up spending a mere $70,000
to make sita sings the blues legal to
show for free and legal to share for
free.
If I wanted some other model,
it would have been more than that
$70,000 to be able to give it away.
Uh,
but I'm not doing that with a new film.
The new film,
I'm making an illegal film.
All of my music choices have to do not
with their licenses,
but with the content and meaning and
resonance of the songs.
Most songs have a kind of cultural
resonance that is related to the point
in time they were circulating.
For example,
this land is mine,
you know,
refers directly to this period of the
sixties.
Yeah.
It has a cultural resonance because of
that.
Which a new song.
If I commissioned a new song,
sort of like that,
it wouldn't have the same meaning at
all.
No,
definitely no.
Songs like that they pick up.
It's really interesting to watch what
happens to a song across time because it
picks up again,
it's embedded in the context and that
context grows and develops and
transforms.
The song is really a mutable entity.
You know,
it,
it transforms tremendously as it moves
across time.
Yeah.
And that.
And that meaning comes from the
audience.
It doesn't come from even the person
that wrote it,
let alone the copyright holder.
Right.
The value of it comes from us.
Okay.
So back to this land is mine.
So when I watched that,
it produced a lot of mixed feelings.
I mean the first was that it was very
blackly humorous and you know,
you have this stirring propaganda stick
anthem,
light music in the background.
It's sort of overblown.
I'm the singer,
he,
he amplifies the emotional resonance of
it and then you have this just nonstop
carnage in the background to this,
to this stirring music and then.
But what's really strange about it as
far as I was concerned is that it's
eerily beautiful and that's something
that's,
it seems to be a perverse and remarkable
element of all of your films is that
they deal with extremely harsh
realities,
metaphysical and,
and genuine,
but you have this amazing capacity to
generate these complex,
beautiful images and to set them in a,
in a,
in an equally beautiful relationship to
the music.
And so,
I mean,
I didn't know and still don't know what
to make of the film because you don't
often see what you might describe as
stunningly beautiful satire,
stunningly beautiful artistic satire.
I don't know.
Mad magazine was pretty stunningly
beautiful
back back in the day.
It hadn't had like the best artists
working for it.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
But you're,
you're,
there's an element to what you're doing,
especially with the juxtaposition of the
music that seems to elevate it,
in my opinion,
to something like the level of high art.
What's high?
What's low?
Well,
thank you.
I thank you for the compliment.
I can't really respond to any,
anything other than thanking you.
So your aesthetic sense and the style
that you've developed,
do you have sources for that?
Do you have influences that,
that,
that helped you,
helped you develop that particular
style?
I mean,
I know it's a foolish question,
dial star artists where they get their
ideas,
but I'm,
I'm wondering how it is that you came up
with the concepts that you're working
with?
Well,
graphically,
some of the style is determined by the
software that I use.
So this land is mine and all the song
scenes and Sadomasochism,
arch,
flash and flash.
The way I use it,
it's what we call a cutout style.
We're all drawing shapes and I'll,
I'll move them in relation to each
other,
but the ships themselves don't bend or
anything they're just cut out is an
animation technique where people would
literally cut out shapes from paper and
move them around under a camera.
So that's part of the style,
uh,
with this land is mine in particular I
was looking at ancient Assyrian art and
ancient Egyptian art.
Some of that is reflected.
There's like little border of flowers
which comes from a Syrian art.
Um,
those are the main things,
a cutout style and this Syria and stuff.
And
when you,
when you made this way or this morning,
did you have the sadomasochism film in
mind or did that emerge afterwards?
No,
I knew,
I knew I wanted to make this film about
Passover and that's why I watched exodus
and that's how sadomasochism,
I mean that's how this land is.
Mine came to be.
So I just knew I wanted to do a film
about Passover.
I didn't know what it was gonna be
because I had never read the Old
Testament before.
And reading exodus was of course an eye
opener.
Um,
and the film,
I don't,
I didn't imagine what the film was gonna
be like when I started it other than the
topic I would work around.
But the way the film is actually shaping
up is a surprise to me.
So we should probably walk everyone
who's listening through the film itself.
So you've created a variety of what
appear at least to be at the moment,
to be animated shorts that detail out
different episodes in the biblical
narrative surrounding essentially
surrounding Moses.
There's more to it than that,
but certainly surrounding Moses and so
does the film,
does the film essentially concentrate
solely on exodus or are there other
elements of,
of Old Testament stories that are you
that you're including?
It's really just exodus,
leviticus and deuteronomy and numbers
all have bits of exodus in them.
Right?
Right.
So it's basically the story of Moses.
It's a story of Moses,
right?
It's the story of the exodus and then be
establishment of the,
you know,
the Tabernacle and the priesthood and
the religion.
Right.
That's sort of a mean.
It's regarded as the birth of the Jewish
people.
Right.
And so now you said that when you were
growing up,
you observed Passover but not much else.
Yeah.
So,
but you're,
it's not unreasonable,
I think to observe that there appears to
be something like a deep religious
sensibility in your,
in your work.
I mean,
you seem to be treating the stories with
a tremendous amount of respect.
And so what,
what do you,
what do you think's welling up from
inside of you to do that?
Well,
I'm glad you recognize the risk and the
respect.
Any respect for this was like I,
I approached these stories with an open
mind and an open heart and was expecting
to find some wisdom in them.
Uh,
when I began this project I thought I'm
going to explore the religion of my
father.
My father came from a religious Jewish
family,
but he wasn't really religious when I
was growing up.
Although he had,
he,
he wanted us to observe Passover.
I guess as part of our,
he want us to have some Jewish identity.
He wanted us to be in touch with our
heritage as Jews,
but it was a bit muddled.
Um,
like we,
we were forbidden from observing any
Christian holidays.
There was no Christmas in our house,
whereas a lot of secular Jews do observe
Christmas.
There was like a really half assed
Hanukkah and there were no other high
holy days.
And my dad was an atheist.
So after spending years reading many
different versions of exodus and
commentary on it and things relating to
it and trying to understand it and
trying to find some way to connect to
it.
What happened was I realized that I had
found the religion of my father and that
was atheism.
So I,
I became sort of a born again,
atheist reading this stuff.
My neutrality towards the religion
changed to a kind of a boring towards
it,
um,
which is,
which is not to take away from.
It's important,
you know,
as a cultural foundation,
right?
Like I live in western culture and these
texts are stories that everybody knows
to some extent and you know,
they're very important and I,
I respect them for that reason that
there were like a cultural touchstone
for everyone.
But I did not emerge from exodus within,
you know,
I had like less connection to God than I
had ever had in my life.
I actually had like a spiritual crisis,
like,
you know,
it was really hard for me to have any
kind of sense of a power greater than
myself after reading this and,
and working with it.
And that's also been the case as a
consequence of doing the animation.
Yeah.
Because you know,
animation is like a meditation when you,
when you made an old story,
it's just a long out meditation on it
and sometimes insights can pop up while
you're working on it.
I mean,
it's just like in your face everyday.
I have there,
there are insights that I have.
One of them,
a lot of them are comparative religion
insights because the previous film with
Sita sings the blues.
So in this film I included Aaron a lot
in Sita sings the blues.
I left out Luckman who is a Rahm's
brother.
And I decided not to do that here even
though with a lot of these stories when
they're turned into films,
Erin is made into this minor character
and a lot of things that Aaron does in
movies they show Moses doing,
like casting the staff down and it turns
into a snake that was,
that was Aaron's business.
But anyway,
I showed Aaron in this and I fought
about how both stories have these
brothers,
they have like the big important,
memorable brother and the other brother
who actually carries out quite a bit of
the work.
Um,
so that's a similarity and of course
both stories also have a really gruesome
scene after what we normally think of as
the end.
Like with exodus,
especially growing up with Passover,
I'd always thought the story was the
Hebrews were slaves and then you know,
they were free,
right?
Like the end is,
they're free.
They crossed the Red Sea to get away
from the Egyptians for Ray.
And of course what actually happens in
the story after that is there's this
Hebrew on Hebrew slaughter because of
the golden calf and a whole bunch of
those Hebrews who were liberated,
they die.
Yeah.
Well,
liberation turns out to be a very
complicated thing.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny when I,
when I watched the Americans go into
Iraq,
you know,
with her initial optimism and then the
absolute disintegration of the Iraqi
state,
I thought,
well,
and then the failure to produce
something,
you know,
stable.
And as a consequence,
I thought,
well,
a little bit of exodus would have gone a
long ways.
It was quite funny in some sense because
in a black way,
because of course the people who invaded
Iraq who planned the invasion or
we're at least nominally committed
Christians and I thought,
well,
they took out the tyrant like just as
the Hebrews escape from retirement,
let's say,
but you know,
exodus lays it out pretty clearly is you
escaped from tyranny into the desert and
that's no joke and it's 40 years,
right?
It's three generations before the desert
disappears and in the desert there's
nothing but inter,
inter tribal warfare and,
and,
and the,
and the conflict around new emerging
values,
which is of course that the conflict
between the idealization of the golden
calf and,
and the necessity for the new rules that
Moses imposes.
It's no picnic and then meet.
A lot of the old testament is like that.
Even.
I've been a series of lectures.
I don't know if you know about this,
but I've done 12 lectures on the old
testament that have actually become
quite popular.
I think the first one has about three
quarters of a million views and I'd been
attempting to treat the stories with as
much respect as I can because like you,
I believe that their foundation stories
and um,
I would say that my respect for them has
actually grown and,
and,
and my relationship with whatever you
might regard as transcendent has been
improved by that,
but
be that as it may even in the story of
Abraham,
you know,
he's called forward by God to go out
into the world.
He's an old man by that time,
right?
He's 75 years old.
He should have left his family,
his father's house and,
and his kinsmen long before.
But God calls him on an adventure to go
out into the land of the stranger and to
leave his home.
And you know,
it just goes terribly badly.
For Abraham,
it means the first thing he encounters
is a famine.
And then he moves into the tyranny of
Egypt.
And then,
you know,
the Pharaoh takes his wife.
So it's one of the things that you can
say about the old testament is that it's
not easily optimistic in any sense of
the word,
but the Passover story kind of is as,
it's as people observe it,
like when you read the Passover story,
it's just this nice part and that,
like I say that other part,
that later chapter,
we never discussed that at Passover and
you know,
the closest will come as 40 years in the
desert.
Like I didn't know that the Jews
wandered the desert for 40 years.
I didn't know they kill each other.
Right.
And,
and this is something that's similar to
the Ramayana because the Ramayana is
frequently told without the last
chapter,
without the authority Aconda,
which is the difficult part,
right.
Which I think is the richest and most
interesting part of the whole story.
So I focused on it in Sita sings the
blues.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
I mean I think that what
the most valuable parts of these stories
are the most difficult and other parts
that are left out.
Most people don't know about.
You have to actually read them.
It will be the most useful parts because
life is full of difficulty and so with
you over,
if you leap over the parts of the
stories that are pessimistic and dark,
then you missed part of what the stories
are trying to teach you about how to
prepare for catastrophe mean it says,
obviously in the exodus story,
the fact that the Hebrews escaped from
tyranny is presented as a good segue and
even as something that God wills,
but it's by no means a straightforward
passage from tyranny to the promised
land.
I mean,
in Moses doesn't make it to the promised
land right here.
He dies before he gets there.
Yeah,
and even the promised land is not nearly
as much fun as it's been as we have been
led to believe,
right?
Like they're,
they're constantly the Jews that are
constantly falling short.
Right?
They're constantly and God,
they're never getting their shit
together.
You know,
God just keeps,
you know,
God's ambivalence towards persists.
Yeah.
Well,
well,
and I also think that's very realistic
because there are very few times in life
where even if you're not suffering from
the tyranny of other people or yourself,
that it's very difficult to walk the
proper,
straight and narrow path and to keep
everything organized and to keep things
going.
Property.
And there's no,
there's never any shortage of severe
challenges.
Yeah.
So in that,
even if you're chosen by God,
let's say,
there's no shortage of severe
challenges,
you also see that in all the other
stories in the Old Testament.
I mean,
even when God is walking with someone,
say like Abraham or Noah for that
matter,
it's pretty still pretty much nonstop
carnage.
I mean,
noah,
Noah has his family together and um,
his generations are perfect,
right?
And he walks with God so he's properly
oriented in the world,
but he still has to build the Ark and,
and get through the damn storm and,
and,
and be humiliated by his children at the
end.
And it's,
it's,
it's very rough business.
So in the,
in one of your,
uh,
shorts and I don't know the name of it,
it's the one where the,
I guess it's the one that specifically
deals with the Passover where the
Egyptian firstborns are all killed.
Yeah.
What's that one called?
Death of the firstborn.
Egyptians go,
hold on.
There we go.
And appropriate title.
I can't help but harbored the suspicion
that you had a fair bit of sympathy for
the Egyptians.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
they had some great art.
Yes.
Yeah.
And you do a wonderful job by the way of
incorporating that into that film.
It's not wanting to spectacularly
beautiful.
Well thank you.
And they had religion and uh,
so doing visual research for this
project,
there was not a lot of really great
ancient Hebrew art possibly or probably
because it's against the religion to
make art.
You're not supposed to make graven
images.
So
in terms of coming up with a style that
evoked this,
I had to,
I was looking at art from the region and
I was like,
oh,
it's all Egyptian and Syrian.
Those are the ones.
Those are the people there that made the
art fantastic art.
It breaks my heart that that's supposed
to be evil,
right?
That,
that,
that art,
which actually moves me when I look at
it,
is what we're supposed to smash,
right?
Like,
that's,
that's what we're commanded to destroy
because it's,
it's all full of idols.
Um,
I,
I'm not down with that.
So I just naturally was going to
sympathize with the Egyptians.
This is all we'll do.
There's a real tension there that I
think is worth thinking about,
you know,
because I understand why from a
psychological perspective and understand
why there was an injunction against
making images and you know,
you see the same thing,
kept it out right now with isis say in
the Middle East where they're destroying
the world,
for example,
all the great Buddhist art and all those
ancient monuments,
which of course is an absolute and utter
catastrophe,
but
religion,
I mean they were following it better
than we do.
Right,
right.
Well,
so,
so the conundrum seems to me to be that,
and this is also played out in the story
of exodus with the golden calf,
is that no,
the idea of God is supposed to be
something at least in principle,
that you can't really grip,
that you can't really encapsulate that
know that you can't dogmatically
represent because then it turns into an
idol and an article in etiology are very
much the same thing.
And I think ideology is terribly
dangerous.
You know,
because you take something concrete like
an axiom of some sort,
you,
that's very concrete.
And then you make that your highest
value and it narrows you and,
and restricts you and also makes you
incredibly dangerous.
And so the idea that there's a great
danger in idolization I think is a,
is a very,
very powerful notion.
And so I think that's what informed the
restrictions against making graven
images of God because you end up
confusing the image with the
transcendent reality.
Right?
And then you think that you understand
it and you have it in your hands,
but it certainly does seem to have some
pretty dramatically negative
consequences when the consequence of
that is the absence of visual arc in any
profound sense.
And also this injunction to destroy the
idols of well of the foreigner or,
or of the,
of the person who's heretical or,
or,
and I,
I'm not exactly sure how to.
What would you say?
I'm not exactly sure what the mediating
path is between those two extremes and I
think a real artist and,
and,
and I,
I definitely think that you belong in
that category is someone who isn't using
idols as representation because you're
using your artistic talent to push
beyond what you already know.
Like it's a form of exploration rather
than a form of Canada [inaudible] or,
or categorization,
right?
It's,
it's a,
it's a journey into the unknown and an
extension of the way that people think.
And I think of that as a way of uniting
with the transcendent rather than trying
to encapsulate it in some sort of
formulate box.
But there is a great danger of that kind
of formula formulization.
So anyways,
there is that danger and that's,
that is of course the commonest
interpretation of the injunction against
idols.
But I think,
I mean it's,
it's never borne out,
right?
It's like any injunction against that
kind of a idolatry has never resulted in
the absence of idolatry ever.
Uh,
and we can clearly do it with abstract
concepts.
We can clearly do it.
You have a clearly don't need images to
do this.
You could argue that you could do it
with words just as effectively
you never have anything.
And so if it doesn't work,
I wondered while I was working on the
film,
whether it might have been a simple and
misunderstood injunction against using
Egyptian hieroglyphics and that it,
it was a requirement to use submitted
written language rather than Egyptian
because Egyptian hieroglyphics are full
of things that fly in the air and things
that crawl on the ground and things that
swim in the sea and men and women.
All that stuff.
Because I was working on these little
animated hieroglyphs and I was like,
maybe it was just this.
Which would have made sense,
right,
because
because anti-depression when when these
stories were written down and they were
promoting the Semitic language,
that's what you were supposed to use.
Well now we've put it in some sense in
the same categories,
the dietary prescriptions,
right?
Because the best evidence for the reason
for those dietary prescriptions isn't
hygiene or anything like that.
It's don't eat the food that you're,
that the people who worship other gods
eat.
Right.
And there's a variety of,
of useful reasons for that.
Certainly one of them.
Is that it?
Yep.
Yeah.
Well it's a price at an advantages that
the people you eat with your kinsmen and
your tribesmen pretty much by
definition.
And so if you share a pallet,
if you share a menu and there and you
share it restrictions,
it's much easier for you to socialize
with the people who have the same
restrictions that you do.
So it seems to be a reasonably
intelligent way of keeping your culture
cohesive.
While it certainly,
it certainly worked for a very long
period of time so that that would be an
idea that's in keeping with that,
isn't it?
You certainly don't use the idol
representations of the people who you
are not because then you integrate with
them and your and your culture
disappears.
Right.
And you don't use their language and you
don't use.
You don't write down things that they
can read.
Right.
But so much of these books of Moses were
about being different from your
neighbors.
Like don't let your neighbors corrupt
you are different from your neighbors.
And interestingly,
I was raised with that,
right?
Like my father,
the atheist Jew was adamant about
not doing the Christmas things when I
went to school.
Uh,
you know,
they would have Christmas projects in
the winter and he would say,
just tell your teacher you don't have to
do this project,
you're Jewish.
He never said you don't have to do the
project because you're an atheist just
because you're Jewish.
Right.
And so we maintain some sort of
difference in spite of not actually
practicing Jewish religion.
Really.
Yeah.
Well that's one of the things that's
always been interesting,
interesting to me about Judaism,
particularly in a mystery I would say.
And you know,
I think there are very many ways of
believing in God and one way of
believing is conscious and that would be
the sort of belief that you can state as
I believe or I don't believe,
and I think in some sense that's the
weakest form of belief and it's also the
one that's most easily undermined.
I think the more profound forms of
belief or ones that you act out there
like a dance in some sense and they're
built into your behavioral coding and
they're not so easily criticized and
undermined because they don't really
operate at an intellectual level.
No.
Like,
like for example,
watching your videos
and it's not,
they're not reduceable to an
intellectual exercise.
You know,
I can't watch them.
And first of all I can't say exactly
what it is that you're up to.
And even if I could lay out a reasonably
comprehensive description of what you
are up to,
which,
which would be by no means complete.
It wouldn't be easy for me to mountain
intellectual attack on that.
Because because of your use use of dance
in some sense with the catapults and
your use of imagery in your use of
music,
it it puts the entire discussion on a
plane that can't be easily reducible to
an intellectual discussion.
And so in Judaism you see this,
and this is the case,
I think with the atheist Jews perhaps
most self evidently is that the rituals
are kept in.
The division is kept and the encoded
actions are kept and the person might
say,
well,
I don't believe in God,
and the proper objection to that might
be something like,
well,
you might say that you don't believe in
God,
but you sure acted out.
It seems to me that,
you know,
people have asked me about my religious
faith,
which is a question that I find quite
intrusive and I'm not that.
No,
not that people don't have the right to
ask it because they certainly do.
But I mean I'm,
I'm sufficiently.
I'm ignorant about my own orientations
in some sense to not know exactly how to
answer that.
But one answer that I find quite useful
and I think fairly truthfulness that are
certainly act as if there's a god and
then the rest of it I leave I suppose in
some sense in a cloud of an,
of as,
of yet into bleakly explored ignorance
because I do believe that human beings
have a relationship with the
transcendent.
Now I see that manifest itself in,
in great art,
for example,
where people seem to be able to reach
beyond to produce something that's a
spectacular,
lasting,
intense emotional and practical
significance.
That's the realm of inspiration,
you know?
And I don't think that we understand
that very well at all and I don't think
that we understand consciousness very
well as well at all in stockton.
I think it is a fundamental element of
being so.
But,
but it is interesting and it in,
in your,
in your work too,
like I see it.
It's interesting to hear you talk about
it.
I see a profound religious,
what would you call it?
Oh
well I see a profound religious spirit
at work and it's so interesting to me
that your experience of reading exodus
and also doing these animations has
actually for you being an increased
sense of divorce from the,
from let's say the realities of the
text.
Yeah,
but you know that.
So the word I use to describe it as I
was bereft,
uh,
after spending all this time with them
because the more time I met with the
tests,
the more time I spent working on this,
the,
just the other less connected to
anything I would call God I felt.
And after I finished those scenes,
it took me a really long time to get
inspiration for finishing the film.
I guess I finished the last scene of it,
of the Moses parts a year and a half ago
and I just could not continue working on
the film because I was thinking like
more Moses,
more old testament and it just made me
feel sick every time I approached it.
Is it possible just out of curiosity
that that was a form of something like
spiritual exhaustion?
Because it'd be.
Your films are very,
very serious and they're,
and they're,
and they're very complex and so I kind
of wonder too,
is if you just haven't like,
drained yourself of,
of,
of inspiration as a consequence of
working on this for so long.
I mean,
they're very complex,
deep themes and you know,
as you said,
they do sit at the bottom of the culture
and it's no joke to mess around with
that kind of thing.
That's true.
But I now see what I was missing.
I mean,
I've,
my Muse has returned so I,
you know,
I could say that I'm not religious,
but I clearly practice like a religious
person because I have a Mus and I'm
inspired by my muse and I have faith in
my muse and I even have prayer that I
say to my muse.
So,
uh,
that's,
you know,
that's a sort of religious lifestyle or
spiritual one anyway.
Yes.
Well,
you.
Okay.
And so you said that you even prayed to
tell.
Tell me,
tell me about the muse.
Okay.
Well,
would you like to hear it?
My Muse prayer?
Sure,
definitely amusing.
Okay.
Our idea which art in the ether that be
named by vision come by,
we'll be done on earth as it is an
abstraction.
Give us this day,
our daily spark,
and forgive us our criticisms as we
forgive those who critique against us
and lead us not into stagnation,
but deliver us from ego for dynasty
division,
the power and the glory forever.
Amen.
That certainly seems to me to be like,
I would think of that as a,
as a,
a mantra to open up the gateway between
you and this transcendent forest that
allows people religious inspiration.
I mean,
and you're doing something like clearing
out your ego and I think it is very
interesting that it's associated with
the,
with the,
uh,
the Lord's prayer,
especially with regards to,
you know,
you make this interesting identity
between criticism and temptation.
No.
In one of the things,
of course it does interfere with
stagnation.
Yes.
But yes,
but deliver us from criticism.
I think you something you,
yeah.
Faded,
but deliver us.
Oh wait,
wait,
but deliver us from ego.
Oh boy.
I will forgive us our criticisms as we
forgive those who critique.
Yes,
that that well and the criticism that
that.
That's a very interesting element of it
too because it's often the case.
One of the things that I teach my
students when they're writing is to get
a critical spirit the hell out of the
way to begin with.
No,
because what people try to do is produce
and edit at the same time and you
actually can't do that.
What you have to do is open yourself up
to the to the to to the creative process
and all of its errors because when you
first start,
it's going to be very much error
written,
but you have to allow yourself to
manifest that ever written spark of
creativity to begin with and keep the
criticism at bay and also the ego
element I think is extremely interesting
because to the degree that you're trying
to bend your artistic production to the
proximal demands of your ego,
then you actually.
You've polluted you propaganda is it and
you reduce it.
I would say to something like an idol
because it then it.
Then it's to serve some other master
rather than whatever it is that is
supposed to be in some sense flowing
through you.
That's a good way to put it.
I have a real problem doing work for
money.
I love money and what I like to do is do
my work and then encourage people to
send me money.
But the whole,
this whole thing where somebody says,
I'll give you this money if you do the
work.
I've done that.
It's just called being a professional
artist and it never works out for me.
I mean,
I did this,
a segment of this commercial film.
Um,
ironically it was Kahlil Gibran,
the profit,
uh,
all animated and I did it for money.
I got paid well.
I thought it was never going to animate
again after that because it burned me
out so badly.
It was a really unpleasant process
because the authority in this was not my
muse.
The authority was the people with the
money.
Really.
The money you subjugating the greater to
the lesser.
Yeah.
And if I do that even a little bit,
it's,
the feeling is horrible and I can.
I liken it to how I imagine
prostitution,
like all the warnings about prostitution
and what it,
what it does to your soul,
even if you think it's Hunky Dory.
Um,
I,
I can relate to that when I do the work
for money,
it's really different than when I'm
doing it.
Right.
Okay.
So which of your prayer.
So now you've modified the Lord's
prayer.
Yeah.
And so did you write that down?
Like how,
how in the world did you come up with
this?
Thank you for actually telling me.
I'm quite amazed that you did because of
course it's a peculiar thing and I mean
that in the best possible sense,
but it seems also to be quite a private
thing
out about it since,
I mean the thing with the blues is it
was such a profoundly weird experience
making that film and it was so much like
the channeling and it was so much just
getting out of my own way.
Um,
that I,
I did want to share that.
I mean because people would ask me these
questions.
So how did you make that?
And it's like,
I don't ever really know,
Jeremy,
you said you got out of your own way,
you know,
in one of the things that,
that,
that I've been struck by with regards to
both the prophetic tradition in the Old
Testament and also the passion story in
the New Testament,
is that there's a tremendous emphasis in
those stories are on getting out of your
own way,
you know,
because the idea is supposed to be.
This is part of the idea of the dying
and resurrected hero of course,
is that you're supposed to let
everything in you that gets in your way,
burn away and die so that whatever can
flow through you that,
that has true value and that's oriented
towards the highest good,
let's say.
Which I think is what you're doing when
you're establishing a relationship with
your muse,
is that there isn't anything that's part
of the Ego,
part of that critical capacity that's,
that's inappropriate or part of,
let's say,
worldly concerns that's interfering with
your ability to reach beyond yourself.
And that's,
that's a holy calling.
I would say it's.
And maybe it's the primary holy calling.
I think,
I certainly think it is,
it's,
it seems to me to be the case and I,
I do think in some sense that's what
artists act out when they're really
being artists because they're,
they're establishing a relationship with
the source of inspiration,
whatever that is.
And it's not like we understand that we
don't understand that it's something
that's very,
very deep.
Yeah,
I do.
Or I
do believe if I have beliefs,
I do believe that regarding it as
something that comes from elsewhere,
something bigger than yourself is for
me.
Helpful.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't like this idea that it's all me.
I'm connected to other people and
connected through culture and through
language which is culture and through
art,
which is culture.
I mean I'm just like a fish swimming in
a sea of culture on a,
what we call creating is really
absorbing and processing all of this
culture that I'm a part of and just
expressing a little bit out.
I'm very dubious.
And the idea of originality.
For example,
I wrote an essay about that,
the cult of originality.
I think that's delusional.
Maybe difficult part of the originality
idea is that it's it,
it's tied up with ego
because I think that people can be
spectacularly original,
but I don't know if you give to
attribute that to their ego,
you know,
Tibet part of them that you call me and
the mind is a very strange place because
there's obviously a part of it that we,
that we identify with as ourselves.
That would be,
to me that would be the ego and it's
obviously it and it's the thing I think
that is capable of generating eagle
testicle criticisms and,
and standing on principles for self
defense or for dominance display or
something like that.
That's,
you know,
it's sort of a,
it operates at a relatively low level of
moral virtue.
But then there's parts of us that are
obviously far beyond ourselves,
you know,
and that's the part,
for example,
to generate dreams and visions and
perhaps even ideas.
Because one of the things I really liked
about reading curl young,
one of the things he made me really
conscious of was the fact that.
And nature of course talked about this
in the same way.
To some degree is that it's not so much
that you have ideas,
it's the one you could say,
no,
don't be so sure about that.
The ideas have you.
So there's that,
and then the next thing is,
well,
it isn't so much that you think up the
ideas,
it's that you encountered them if you
open yourself up to the possibility of
encountering them and it is like a
process of discovery rather than a
process of origination,
let's say.
And that's also so you could say,
even if you're like a biological
materialist,
which I actually don't think you can be
because biological materialism doesn't
help us account for consciousness in the
least.
So far.
We don't have a good theory of
consciousness.
You're saying like a biological
materialist theory of consciousness
because I'm a biological materialists.
Biology exists.
Well,
yes,
of course.
I just don't.
I just don't think that it provides.
It isn't sophisticated enough to provide
answers to some of the most fundamental
questions about human existence that
we're.
Right.
No,
I agree with that.
And you know,
the idea that you just expressed that
when you're in a creative,
uh,
when you're engaging in the creative
process with whatever it is that you're
praying to,
let's say that you're opening yourself
up to something that's beyond you.
Now you could say that that comes from
deep within the human psyche,
which is a psychoanalytic way of
thinking about it and,
and I think a reasonably appropriate way
of thinking about it,
but I don't think it's any more
reasonable in some sense than making
the,
generating the hypothesis that you're
opening yourself up to unknown forces in
the cosmos because I think that's just
as just as intelligent and account for
the phenomena as the,
as the,
as the former one,
we are in contact with things that are
beyond us.
And I do think that that's a large part
of what the artist actually demonstrates
and keeps and keeps in front of people.
I think beauty in particular is a
powerful force for that.
And that's,
I mean,
when I've watched your videos really,
they are so beautiful that they,
they virtually bring me to tears.
Aw.
Especially in combination with the music
because I'm very sensitive to music,
but you have this unbelievable capacity
for,
for grace and for color and for,
and for deep respect for the music,
which I think is also really quite
remarkable.
Like your noi often see movies that use
good music,
but they don't have much respect for the
music.
They'll,
they'll cut it,
you know,
in the middle of a phrase or something
like that.
Um,
I remember the movie Magnolia was a real
exception to that,
that,
that move uses music beautifully.
And a
woody allen is very good at using music
beautifully.
And so is,
um,
who is the director of the shining?
I'm Kimra Kubrick Kubrick.
Hey.
I mean,
he loves music and his,
his,
his work a clockwork orange has some of
the same kind of perverse,
but that some of your animation has,
you know,
because he,
he used those great beethoven pieces
that were,
that were transformed into electronic
music by Walter Wendy Carlos and uh,
and set these brutal scenes of mayhem to
beautiful music,
which was also,
I think,
a very profound thing to do.
It kind of,
I mean,
of course Germany is the home of
Nazi-ism and it's also the home of
Beethoven and Bach and so you really
can't separate those things in some
sense and so,
okay,
so let's go to the copyright issue to
some degree now.
Now you're,
you're not a fan of the idea of
copyright and,
and that's,
that's interesting to me because it has
been arguably a reasonably
efficient way for people to,
let's say protect theft of they're
protecting themselves from theft if
their intellectual property.
Although I would say that's broken down
quite badly now for people like
musicians because their work is so
distributable.
Are you against copyright for all forms
of intellectual property or why don't
you tell us a little bit about your,
your ideas?
Well,
you say that is if intellectual property
exists,
what is intellectual property?
Well,
I guess to some degree I'll take the
easy way out and say that's a legal
issue,
but I would,
you know,
I would say that at least to some
degree,
intellectual property is the consequence
of abstract work when you.
Because it's,
it's certainly possible to work
abstract,
deconstructing something like you're
constructing your movies or perhaps a
book and it seems to me that it's not
unreasonable to propose that that
deserves some of the same ownership
protection that a physical entity like,
uh,
I'm not,
I'm not sure that there's,
there's some level of similarity between
you owning your house and not allowing
other people then you owning the more
abstract work that you've done.
But I'm not,
and I'm certainly not attempting to
engage you in an argument about the
benefits of copyright.
I presume that you have a very well
thought through stance on s and m.
well was it begins with.
It begins with acknowledging that
culture is not property.
It just didn't.
And what we were just talking about a
few minutes ago where,
where does this stuff come from?
You know,
it comes from something bigger than
ourselves.
We were just talking about,
you know,
we do not actually originate this.
We certainly work,
but I didn't originate any of the work
that I'm putting out there.
I mean,
I just stated it.
Uh,
but we don't own children either.
You know,
we let our children go out into the
world.
If you,
if you want to own your child for 96
years and you know,
control everything,
well then that serves you,
right?
You get exactly what you deserve.
If I do that,
you get a dead trial.
Basically you get a crippled,
you know,
non human being.
And the thing with cultural works is
they,
like I say,
I'm a fish swimming in there,
you know,
it's like water.
What happens when you enclose water?
It becomes stagnant,
it becomes nasty,
it becomes toxic and you know,
I know that for my own work it has to go
out in the world and it has to continue
circulating and for me personally,
copyright interferes with that because
you put a monopoly around something.
If,
if I,
if one person or even if I am licensed
my copyrights to others when when it's
centrally controlled,
it does not move.
And I did a lot of experiments.
The Sita sings the blues and by far the
best way to get it into the world is to
just let people carry it into the world.
Great.
They have.
That's certainly what I've experienced
as well and people are also taking more
lectures and cutting them into pieces,
which is not something I expected and
then putting up pieces of different
length on,
on,
um,
on the,
on the net,
and I've had companies contact me and
say,
you know,
for um,
for a fee we'll more or less hunt
these people down and it's forced your
copyright.
And I thought,
well no one,
I'm,
I'm more thinking about the message in
the bottle approach to this and I'm
willing to let go where,
where it to let the wind blow where it
wants to blow,
let's say he could put it that way
and I'll say if you're making more money
that way because as you just pointed
out,
people are sending,
people want to support you,
they want to support you because they
actually see your work.
Right.
If you were taking down all these,
all these instances of your work getting
seen because of copyright,
fewer people would see your work.
The audience is the most efficient
distribution machine that exists.
It's definitely been a case for me and
I've been fortunate too because I've
been involved in some political
controversy over the last year and some
people that I know who,
who,
who have been involved in say let's say
broadly similar political controversies
have been demonetized on Youtube,
you know,
and I'm outside of that because
everything I put up is free and people
are perfectly willing to support me.
But I mean it's also very fortunate that
a new thing that this,
these new platforms for direct support
of creative people let's say have just
emerged and developed,
which is,
you know,
thank,
thank God for that because it's very
difficult for creative people to
monetize their production.
Yup.
So,
so now.
All right,
so
art is just to say something about more
on this,
you know,
with,
with my films going out for free,
but benefit to me is that far more
people see them that way than would see
them if I were trying to control them
and trying to get people to pay me to
see the thing.
So I made more money releasing sita,
sings the blues for free than I ever had
before in my career where everything was
copyrighted,
the consequences of all my comic strips
being copyrighted is that people just
don't see them.
So yeah,
so just releasing it as good,
but the other assets,
so that,
that's the benefit to me,
uh,
the benefit to society is that you
overcome like a form of societal brain
damage when you ignore copyright.
And I gave a talk called copyright is
brain damage.
You can look that up,
but if you,
if you look at all of us are neurons and
a great mind and all of us transmit and
receive information,
copyright blocks that function or in an
attempt to control that function.
I mean,
of course you can't,
you can't have a brain with totally
uncontrolled,
you know,
firing of sign apses,
that's madness.
But I really think that each human being
shares work that they love.
So if you just let humans share work
that they love and you know,
they naturally will not share work that
they don't love,
then you end up with a really healthy
system.
And you know,
really good works are going to succeed
in that system.
Whereas controlling things with
copyright,
is this artificial damage to that
system?
Well there's also been a Sarah bit.
It's crooked tree in relationship to
that.
In recent I would say perhaps Disney is
more responsible for that than any other
organization,
you know.
And so it was Disney that was
instrumental in getting copyright
extended from 50 to 75 years.
And I really did think that that was a
form of crime because some of those
early Disney movies and I would put milk
in that category particularly are are
incredibly culturally significant.
And to forestall
a proper discussion of those cultural
artists.
Alex I think is truly damaging.
And it was a travesty that that
copyright extension was granted
over and over again.
And Disney is not the only one.
I mean most of our cultural heritage is
controlled by five big corporations.
Almost everything now.
I mean everything is owned by someone
and once it's owned it can be sold to
someone else.
And it all ends up in the hands of,
you know,
buy a calm and Sony everything.
So now with regards to copyright,
do,
do you draw a distinction?
What about patents and things like that?
Do you think that they are technically
different?
No,
I have a problem with patents,
although my expertise is not in the area
of patents though the one legal concepts
that is classified as intellectual
property,
which is a misnomer that is not
completely fundamentally bankrupt.
His trademark,
because the trademark theoretically has
something to do with fraud and you know,
you need,
you don't need or desire some mechanism
to,
to uh,
control or punished fraud.
So roof arc,
trademark alone would be that.
It's not usually used that way.
It's usually abused is as much as
anything under the intellectual property
label,
but at least it has some.
You could make some excuse for it to
exist.
Right,
right.
So yeah.
Well,
I mean,
part of it,
I guess part of the claim for the
protection of originality,
we might say it's also the protection
you could argue for,
for the,
for genuineness you don't like,
I might want to know that and maybe
legal protection can help with this,
that I might want to know that the thing
that I'm watching or the thing that I'm
consuming is actually produced by the
person who said that they produced it.
So if I go on your website and I've
watched it,
Nina Paley animated short,
I want to make sure that it isn't
something someone copying you and using
your identity as a,
as a,
as a form.
Well,
it's a form of parasitism essentially.
So
yeah.
But the thing is I don't,
I don't have a lot of need for that
largely because I do free my work.
So most people are aware of something
that's by me is by me,
the,
you know,
there's I guess some danger or the way I
might invoke trademark law is if
somebody edited something of mine,
everyone's welcome to edit and
redistribute it.
But if they said that the edit and
redistribution was mine,
it was like,
no,
you know,
like,
like the work I did is mine.
But you have to take responsibility for
that edit and redistribution.
I'm not responsible for your edit and
redistribution.
So if they add some message to it that
is not mine,
I don't want that attributed to me.
And I suppose I could invoke trademark
or something to do that,
I don't know.
Something,
but really would do is just go and say,
Hey,
I never said that.
Yes.
Well that's a lot simpler than engaging
in legal battles were roughly the
equivalent of a fairly serious disease.
Yes,
I took a legal valid nonviolence.
I don't want that system.
Yeah,
well it's certainly a way of keeping
your life simpler and unless,
you know,
unless you get attacked by something
that's truly malevolent and of course
that can happen from time to time.
Okay.
So let's go back to your masochism.
So it's going to come out in 2018 and
I'm,
I'm very much looking forward to that.
Yes,
I bet.
Okay.
So we're a couple of things is,
um,
you know,
it's so interesting because when I watch
your,
your shorts,
I,
I remember a couple of them that have
Moses wandering through the desert with
the pillar of light leading him on and
cloud pillar of cloud.
Yes,
that's right.
That's right.
The cloud.
Yes.
And,
and you've animated that very
interesting way and it's got a kind of
grandeur as well,
which,
which again spoke to me of something
approximating a profound religious
sensibility,
which is partly why I was
surprised by your comments about the,
let's say,
the intellectual effect of your
endeavors on your,
on your relationship with belief.
But
this is the ego,
the ego talk.
Well,
you know,
I think now and then we managed to make
it a muse to muse talk.
Well maybe a little bit,
but maybe a little bit.
You're going to hear from my ego.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Well that's always the danger in talking
to artists,
right?
Because I think generally when you speak
with artists,
you speak to the inferior part of them,
not because their ego is inferior
compared to the ego of other people.
But because the part of them that you
would like to communicate with is
actually the part that's generating the
art already doing it's communication.
Exactly.
That's why I would rather,
I mean in general it's like I speak
better through my art than any other or
an amendment anymore,
right?
It's whatever by his Dick Expressions,
my talking head.
Yes.
Yes,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
And I mean,
part of the reason I wanted to do the
interview though was to find out what
your ego thinks of all of this as well
as to take the opportunity hopefully to
bring your work to,
to perhaps do some people who don't know
about it yet.
And okay.
So now you're making this magnificent,
a production about exodus and about the
old testament and that's a pretty
strange thing to do.
Let's say in the modern world,
what do you have any sense of what
you're hoping that will accomplish?
I know,
I know that you want to launch it and
see what happens and that there's
curiosity associated with that,
but.
But do you have.
Do you have a hypothesis or a theory
about what it is that this is doing in
the broader sense,
how you're contributing to the cultural
conversation?
I,
I'm sure that I do.
I can't access those thoughts right now.
Uh,
but I'll learn a lot more once it,
once it goes out.
All right.
We'll sort of focus it a bit more in
the,
in the Pinocchio Movie,
of course.
Mrs. Very ancient theme in order for the
puppet Marionette,
whose strings are being pulled by forces
beyond his control.
In order for him to become real,
there's a variety of things he has to
do.
He has to learn to tell the truth and he
has to learn not to be a neurotic victim
and he has to learn not to be an
impulsive pleasure seeking,
uh,
a victim of totalitarian processes,
all of those things.
But then he asked to go down to the
bottom of chaos itself and rescue his
father.
I can't help but think that that's part
of what you're doing.
I mean,
you said it yourself in the interview,
right?
Because you said that you were
attempting to make some connection with
the belief of your father and to make
some sense out of it and so you are in
fact going into the void,
let's say,
to rescue your father from the belly of
the whale and,
and you know,
it seems to me that we're in a period
of,
of chaotic instability in our culture
that it actually has a fair bit of
danger associated with it and that I've
felt a strong impulse to go back to
these original stories to find out what
they are and to establish them,
to reestablish them,
let's say his foundation or whatever
that might mean.
It might be my imagination,
but it seems to me that that's
associated,
that that's akin in some sense to what
you're doing with exodus.
Well,
yes,
and when I set out,
I did set out to connect to my father,
your rescue,
my father.
Uh,
but what I have learned in the past year
is that actually I'm looking for my
mother and I think I found her.
Okay.
Well now,
now obviously I'm going to have to ask
you to elaborate on that.
I don't know if I can in words,
right,
like it's still in the process of doing
this,
but it's like,
it's like I have been seeking to connect
with this,
this father,
this God the father,
and also my own father,
which I didn't have the best connection
with.
Nothing,
you know,
nothing really terrible or anything,
just never really connected with him.
And I,
I've longed for that,
right?
Like a lot of my life because the
culture tells me that that's really
important,
you know,
like,
and all the,
all the psychologists say,
oh,
I need a really important thing.
So my whole life it's been like,
oh,
you know,
maybe I,
I wouldn't be messed up about this or
that thing.
Maybe this is a daddy issue.
Now I gotTa get right with my dad even
though he's,
he's dead.
And I'm just like looking and looking
there and it's like,
wait,
I missed something,
right?
Like it's my mother.
It's not,
it's all of our mothers.
And you talked about the original
stories.
You referred to the Old Testament texts,
the original stories.
Well,
they're not,
you know,
we have most of the history of human
religion was not these stories as far as
as far as I have read or learned.
The early human conception of the divine
was female everywhere and we have broken
the connection to that and actually the
story of exodus to me,
what it is is it's the solidifying of
the that change that it was a long
gradual process of moving from goddess
to gods and Goddesses to just God just
one God,
but I'm reaching further back and I
realize,
you know,
when I.
When I found that and when I started
working with that earlier religion where
we have no text for it,
all we have is some artifacts,
many artifacts from all over the world
and beautiful symbols and of course
there's a book by Eric Newman,
the great mother,
which talks about all the symbols
book.
I read that sucker cover to cover
that.
You read the origins.
Have you read the origins and history of
consciousness?
I have eight by Norman.
I have not,
but I did.
I would highly recommend,
but let me just,
I'm with you.
I liked the other.
He writes like a lead weight.
Uh,
it was just good to immerse myself in
that.
So definitely that is what I was longing
for.
And back to the Old Testament.
Those things are in the Old Testament.
They're all portrayed as the other and
the enemies and what we're trying to
stop out,
but they're in there.
So,
so in that way I relate to the Old
Testament,
not the heroes of the Old Testament.
Moses and Aaron and them.
I,
I take
inspiration from the stiff necked people
now it's like,
oh,
it's too stiff.
Neck people.
They're disobedient.
Yes.
That's great.
You know,
those are the,
if there's,
if there's any history to this,
which there probably isn't,
but it's like those are the ones I'm
descended from,
the bad one.
Um,
what was the,
I don't know,
it's interesting because in the
Pinocchio Story and in the classic
stories of,
of journeying to the belly of the whale
or journeying into the underworld,
it's often but not always males who are
doing it.
And the farther,
and it isn't obvious to me
psychologically what happens when a
woman goes to the underworld to rescue
her father isn't clear what she's going
to discover their,
you know,
when it seems to me that you're,
you're,
you're using your creative pseudopods to
sort of feel out that territory and
discover what might be there.
So that seems very important too,
because obviously there's,
there's a problem in our culture and the
problem is how,
what is exactly the relationship between
femininity and women and these,
let's call them patriarchal religions.
I mean there's,
you know,
one of,
one of your criticisms of,
of Christianity.
And of course this is also evident in
Eric moments work,
is that there's,
there's a trinity,
obviously Christianity,
let's say,
and it's a fairly comprehensive.
Well there's God the father and that's
tradition and there's the Holy Spirit
and that you might think about that is
the news.
And there's God in the Sun Forum,
which is,
you know,
you take human being who's,
who's vulnerable and mortal and who's
destined to live on earth,
that those are nice elements of the
divine.
But there's a missing fourth as far as
you're concerned and he thought about as
sometimes constituted by the figure of
Satan,
so that was where evil standard,
but also sometimes constituted by
femininity itself and,
and that,
those two things were often conflated as
well because they were the other.
And um,
and that is a complicated technical
problem because it's not obvious,
it's not precisely obvious what the
divine model is for women,
especially now that they have control
over their reproductive function because
they're sort of half women in the
traditional classic biological sense.
Half the email,
but also in some sense half male freedom
now
control over the reproductive function.
Sadly.
I mean if we lived in that world we
could,
we could talk that way,
but it's.
No,
practically speaking,
women really don't.
Well because of it.
You mean because it's unreliable?
Well,
for one thing,
uh,
are you talking about like a hormonal
pills?
Birth control?
I'm talking about birth control pills.
Well,
like I can't take them right?
Like they,
you know,
they have horrible side effects for me.
I'm quite a few women.
Yes,
definitely.
So it's not like,
it's not like,
oh,
we invented this pill.
I mean,
that's actually one of the,
that's like a great example of,
you know,
our Patriarchal Society,
right?
Like that could be developed for men.
Men wouldn't tolerate the side effects
and back they weren't developing a pill
like that for men.
And then they cut the experiments short
because men weren't,
uh,
weren't tolerating the side effects,
which were worse than the side effects
for women.
But women are going to tolerate that
shit because they're just,
yeah,
we're physically more vulnerable anyway.
It never ends all the old.
This is why I believe from biological
reality.
By the way,
this is what biological materialist just
because regardless of my identity,
regardless of my ideas,
you know,
every month I'm doubled over in pain and
having like very real consequences of
bright of my biology.
Well,
you,
you just did a short about the great
mother and now you know,
I wondered if you had read a book when I
saw that because I know there's
[inaudible] that,
that is an absolutely great book and as
I said,
I would recommend or just history of
conscious.
Obviously it's,
I think it would help answer some of the
questions that you were talking about
today.
I believe you.
Yeah.
So,
and you know,
it was the book that you said he wished
he would have written,
which is hell of a thing for someone
like him to say because he was a
remarkable genius.
And so,
um,
so,
so I guess that the new film and what's
it called when the feature is the great
mother
godmother.
Yes,
exactly.
And so is that now that seems
importantly related to this issue that
you brought up about rediscovering the
connection with your mother going to.
Yeah,
yeah.
My actual mother,
the mother,
the great mother,
right.
I live with my actual mother.
She great and everything,
but we're on a metaphorical.
Yeah.
And that,
that actually is the first scene of
sadomasochism.
So I did the last scene first and then
it took years for me to figure out what
the first scene is.
So That's interesting and there's gonna
be no introduction and no explanation.
It's just,
that's gonna set the stage for the
exodus story.
Is that,
that follow?
Thank you for talking with me.
Thank you for being with me.
I think that,
uh,
I wish you the best of luck with your
film and I hope that exactly what should
happen with it will happen and I'm going
to steal liberally from your films to
illustrate this interview if you don't
mind,
and I'll try to be very respectful and
careful with the editing.
Excellent.
But actually be copying not stealing.
Oh yes.
Okay.
Well thank you very much.
It was a pleasure talking with you.
Thank you.
Likewise.
All right.
Bye.